hi I'm Dan McDonald and along with James
molex Lin Cong Ian Ford and Nicolas
robas were doing the talk conjecturing
theorems in Euclidian geometry ah so
we're previewing some upcoming
functionality or in the user will input
an abstract coordinate free geometric
seem like you might see in that high
school textbook in a scene description
language that we're developing and then
our program will generate a picture
described by that scene and that picture
will include coordinates for the point
in that scene from which we will make
geometric conjectures and after that we
will we are working on code to actually
prove geometric theorems either based on
those conjectures or inputted by the
user
okay let's start so this talk is
conjecturing theorems including in
geometry kind of the team members were
James myself in Peter burns and Nicolas
Robles aren't here and Len so um welcome
and
there you are
okay so kind of an overview of our of
our geometry project so we're looking to
provide tools for solving problems in
plane geometry using the following
workflow so we kind of have four steps
so first is to describe a geometric
scene the second is to draw the scene
the third is to make conjectures about
the scene and the fourth is to prove
theorems about the scene so each of
these a little more in-depth sure good
so describing the scene we're developing
a scene description language within the
WL framework to allow users to
symbolically describe coordinate free
scenes in plain geometry so the emphasis
here is coordinate free we're not
cheating at all you're not you know
telling us where these points are ahead
of time you're just giving us kind of an
abstract geometry problem like you know
these two lines are parallel and these
points all lie in a circle things like
that and we have to figure out the
coordinates on our own so and we're also
creating an entity store with known
theorems in the company and from
accompanying information and all this
information is in this scene description
language so we can do computations on it
so once we've got the scene described in
words we want to be able to draw the
scene and our function for this which is
kind of in a prototype build now but I'm
running from locally from my machine
find geometric scene graphics so here
we're turning scene descriptions into
randomized drawings of those scenes so
if you run this you know with the same
scene description if you run this
function twice you'll get two different
scenes so you know one we want to get
visual representations it seems
obviously to make sure that you know not
the least of which to make sure that
your description
is correct and two for later steps we
actually do want to have coordinates for
points that satisfy the scene so you're
not giving us the cord you don't have to
give us the coordinates it's up to us to
find coordinates that work so then once
we have those coordinates we can use
find geometric conjectures to actually
make conjectures about the original
abstract scene and finally we want to
prove theorems about the scene so this
is still more under development and
we've kind of got two types of provers
so one is the synthetic prover that
Peter is working on that gives human
readable proofs of theorems and the
other is an algebraic prove earth at I
was working on a while ago but we'll
probably pick that up sometime in the
near future that gives very human
unreadable proofs but you know still
nonetheless verify theorems so let's
take a look at we have so start out with
our theorem entity store this is a kind
of a limited local version I have here
it'll be much larger once we actually
expose it so we've got a few theorems
here these are their entity properties
so it's not just the statements of the
theorems but we do have the statements
split up into hypotheses and conclusions
and a lot of other information included
are if we we have links to math world we
also have pictures here are
here are Apophis ease and conclusion so
fins were had burger looks like it's
theorem about squares so anyway on we've
got a few more examples here I'll just
kind of blow through so Pythagorean
theorem
apparently there's apparently the
converse of Pythagorean theorem also
holds Bailey's theorem which we'll see
later
Archimedes midpoint theorem and is our
exam so let's actually see our code in
action right so we usually on these
talks I start out with Bailey's theorem
because as Michael always says Bailey's
never fail EES he doesn't actually say
that but he's never actually said that
so we've got our diagram and so our
hypotheses are so this is in our seen
description language which is subject to
final review so we've got so this this
is not necessarily describing in this
particular picture this is one we lifted
from math world but it will give the
input for our scene drawer later on so
we've got circle through so we've got it
drawing a circle through through these
three points and the circle centered at
oh wow we've also drawing a triangle
through these three points on the circle
and it says o is the midpoint of the
line between a and C which means that
ain't the line segment AC is a-- is a
diameter and our conclusion is that if
these hypotheses hold then the angle ABC
is right angle so let's run this find
you match geometric scene graphics on
our
hypotheses so we're not even giving
ourselves the conclusion to try to draw
this and we I don't yeah let's scroll
down and we get a we had a picture
triangle on on a circle and lo and
behold it looks like Bailey's was right
because this looks like a right angle so
we have this function for returning this
this actual picture we can also return
just the coordinates which are useful
for conjecture code if you want to use
you know find coordinates and apply them
to a scene we can also create these
graphics primitives and then if we plug
those in we draw the picture so no this
was a different picture than this one up
here because the coordinates are
randomized so if I run this again I'll
get different pictures than before okay
so so once we have this picture in these
coordinates our next step and our
workflow is making conjectures so when
you want to come up and talk about that
just talk to me it's working it's
working okay thank you that um so now by
this dancing drug code we already have
this nice graph and like like notice
this is just not a graph it has some
more information so is have all these
geometric primitives so means was
actually inside and we also have the
coordinates so having this information
we can actually try to see you what
other geometrical facts or or what are
the geometric conjectures on this graph
so let's just try this command so now in
this graph in particular we can see that
land B a and line BC
are perpendicular to each other and also
this angle ABC is equal to 19 degree
that this is true if it was telefilm
cell and we didn't return this because
from the output is like we manually
checked all the possible parallel
relations or the possible particular
relations and all the possible like
special angles like 19 degrees 45 degree
30 degrees 60 degree and will return all
the possible conjectures these function
is called fun geometric conjectures and
it can take two more optional input so
the second input means how many this
infinity infinity here is like how many
output do you want so by default you
just return all of them and rather than
return this region language you can also
return a diagram so if you run this it's
like it's not just return these two
outputs it can also highlight in the
graph so in in this graph like these two
lines are perpendicular and the later
one actually there's a very tiny
rectangle there they're they're forming
two clear to each other so you can just
make the conjectures from the graph or
remember our hypothesis is also using
this region language so you can actually
yell before that let's compare the
conclusions with the actual conjectures
so using this graph and for this poly
theorem so you can see the conclusion is
the angle ABC is net in degree and our
second conjecture is ABC is 19 degrees
so this to actually means the second the
conjecture we just returned so you can
replace by one here they are
mathematically equal is just one ba is
particular to line BC so the same thing
is the the same function fun geometric
conjectures is not can only take the
graph as its input it can also just take
this region language so remember our
hypothesis at the very beginning is like
there's a circle there is a triangle and
there's a diameter so we can just take
the three lines as the input and we can
run this conjecture code and of course
it will return the same output and it's
all so it can also take the region
language as input and return this down
diagrams as output so basically for
functionalities on this one function so
you can take either language or graph as
input and you can return either language
or graph as output we have more examples
so we can check parallel perpendicular
special angles we can also check some
things like regular polygons we can
check whether three lines three points
are on the same line we can check
whether whether three lines are
concurrent editing point okay
so let's so let's look at some theorems
that actually very often fail ease so
here's butterfly theorem which is a
little more complicated so here when we
ran it this time we got a we got a good
picture and
and running the kins conjectured code
you can kind of click through and see
all of these conjectures highlighted
we're still playing around with that
with the graphics but one thing to point
out is on these more complicated scenes
the the pictures aren't always good so
if I run this again oh whoops I didn't
initialize this sorry
let's get these hypotheses and here if I
run this you know that pictures kind of
clumped together it's okay running it
again these are very close together so
sometimes you you want to run it first
to make sure you get a good picture
before you go into the conjecture code
so let's hopefully end on a good picture
so that's a good picture and then so so
we've kind of have these steps split up
so that you can you can you can make
sure you get a good scene before you
before you try the conjecture stuff so
here we get 32 conjectures here are 10
of them for this particular picture and
then if you look at we looked at among
those 32 we actually do have you might
not be able to see it but we actually do
have the correct conclusion for this
theorem so let's look through a few more
examples so Pappas is a hexagon theorem
which apparently involves hexagons one
thing we'll note about us doing all
these projects and doing this project in
curating all of these these geometric
theorems I have no idea how to prove any
of these I haven't thought about it at
all they might be real easy they might
be real hard anyway so our scene draw
spit out a pretty good scene here and
looks like the Linds conjecture code was
able to find find the conclusion of the
theorem so just a few more there's
Finn's lair had rigor again with the
squares sometimes our conjecture our
theorem or our scenes our code will not
make assumptions and drawing the picture
that maybe makes a textbook picture look
nice but it will satisfy all the
hypotheses all the same which means the
conclusion should hold
so because Nita's theorem with circles
and triangles and so after this step we
have the synthetic geometry prover which
James will talk about
all right so um this is primarily the
work of Peter Behrens and it arose from
some work that he was doing on
step-by-step solutions in Wolfram Alpha
so the initial target for the the better
people can people hear me okay so the
initial target here was for proofs in
elementary geometry so here we were
picturing ninth grade type proofs so you
have some configuration of lines circles
etc you have maybe some known lengths or
angles and you try to derive some other
lengths angles areas etc the
presentation that we have in mind here
is a two column proof sort of that is
preferred in high school geometry
courses and the basic method is start
with the given facts and apply theorems
to deduce everything that you can all
right so so here is an example of a
scene with three parallel lines and
another line that crosses them one of
the angles is specified to be 30 degrees
and
here is here is the presentation of the
derivation and proof right so a number
of facts are taken as given right those
specified in the scene description and
then the other angles we can derive by
observing that we have parallel segments
computing supplements and so forth
all right so here is another example in
this case we have a line y wz we have
three known and distances and one known
angle and in this case right we call
prove geometric facts this is the same
thing that we called before but in this
case we specify a target fact right so
here we're looking for the the area of
the triangle Y Z X right and so here the
proof simply notes that we have you
can't see the diagram anymore but it
notes here that we have an altitude of
the triangle right and so we can apply
the classic formula to get the area
alright so in recent weeks we have
started looking into whether this same
method will work for actually proving
theorems right so that this wasn't
really the initial goal but surprisingly
it turns out that the answer is at least
a qualified yes okay so first of all
here here is the classic state Daley's
theorem set up again for technical
reasons we have to cede this with
symbolic values of the angles right
something you know a restriction which
were working on ways to remove so we
applied the same method we just apply
theorems more or less blindly and see
what we can discover so we find about 50
facts here
and among them
right you find this right that the the
angle CA B is in fact 90 degrees so this
proof is a bit excessive right in part
because it proves many things beyond
what we asked for so here's a version
where we specify what we're looking for
we're trying to figure out what what
this angle at a is right this gives a
proof which is closer to reasonable
right and in fact if you take a look
here you note the the observation is
that these these radii right the
distances from a OC OBO these distances
are all are alright and that means in
fact you have some isosceles triangles
right so that tells you something about
areas and then in fact that allows you
to solve for the angle at a
unfortunately you know if you take a
look here you'll you'll find that
there's actually two or three
independent complete proofs so the the
fairly naive pruning method that we're
using at the moment doesn't lead to
something completely readable right and
in fact the problem is here we end up
solving a sort of mass and massively
over determined system to discover what
the angle is so you know further
development here is we are trying to see
whether we can refine our our pruning
methods to get a genuinely human
readable proof for theorems right so
we're pretty happy I think with the
situation for concrete ninth grade
geometry problems I think we still have
more work to do on the theorem proving
and whether we stick with this method or
go to a variant I think remains to be
seen
all right so I think that's all I have
to say we'd be happy to take questions
about any or all of the of what we've
discussed here yes
by pi radians
yeah I mean it's it's it certainly is
something that we're considered we're
considering both because of angles and
because we want to support concrete
problems where you know you have a
triangle with say three inches on one
side but but yes so we do have plans to
make that a little more consistent and I
think we do hope to offer users the
option to choose the angle unit of their
preference
which entity store
so not the one up here I think the the
biggest one we're working on currently
has what a little over 100 but there's
cries quite a bit of cleanup before will
really said but right right I mean it'll
hopefully be you know more than more
than just a little over 100 currently
it's kind of our testing suite
[Applause]